[Music]
he's supposed to be a pickup artist and
a pickup artist
at least from my understanding
pick-up artist named francis yes a
pickup artist from
from my understanding
and correct me if i'm wrong here
they're supposed to help you pick up
women not purchase prostitutes
yes that's correct because purchasing a
like to me you know
that's not sound of like oh if you want
a woman in your life purchase a
prostitute that nobody needs a tutorial
on
how to buy an iphone or how to buy a car
right you just go buy one
um you want a tutorial on how to
organically meet a woman
and speak to them but yeah he he quietly
hires hookers and then pretends like
whoa check out all these chicks that are
into me
so let's see this is the beginning of it
you wanna are you in a rush
let's take a drive down the sunset strip
i'm scared
it's just me i'm i'm completely sober
what does that mean by the way that's
his go-to that's his go-to line like you
have to be
dru which always really makes me wonder
what this guy does when he's drinking
right because
like he he thinks that that will make
you [ __ ] like oh don't worry i'm sober
like there aren't any
sober people murder you too yeah there's
plenty of sober
murderers and if anything probably more
of the murderers are probably sober than
they are on drugs
like i would be the opposite like
if some girl's like i don't know i'm a
little nervous i'll be like hey it's
okay
i'm on drugs you want some drugs
better chances now you gotta figure this
guy's a pickup artist so he's gonna pick
up some fly broad right
so this is her entering the vehicle
oh hey oh you're coming in cool
no come on who goes up
and goes get in let's go for a ride like
who does that
i i don't know yeah oh yeah i've been in
it for um
i just completed 12 years yeah that's a
long time
by the way audio only black screen which
just goes to show you that this guy is
such a
ghoul that he's always secretly
recording these things this is
very creepy it's it's yes it's grow
like i'm not saying that there aren't
scenarios in life where you may not want
to
put something on record this is
streaming by the way which is even
creepier
i i could understand if you were going
into a situation where lies might be set
or something when you go i'm going to
record this
just in case to clear my name but like
he just goes out and records er
this is some bob crane from hogan's hero
[ __ ] you know what i mean
this is like auto focus they're gonna
make a movie about francis where greg
kinnear plays the [ __ ] role
yeah fully committed i show up whatever
i do and i
try to do it right and i ain't perfect
you kill me
that's why i always attract military
here get out of here
all right by the way i want to point out
something i appreciate that
i'd like to enter this into evidence if
i may prosecution here um
i would like to point out that notice
how
he's like i'll get in the car whatever
and she gets in the car
notice how the conversation like picks
up from somewhere we were not privy to
yes like this isn't a start of a
conversation this is the continuance of
a conversation so
he was speaking to her off camera
probably paid her
then started the stream in a car and was
like oh
hey let get hello to you you want to get
in the car
he's trying to pretend like this whole
thing's organic but it
appears as if he has purchased a hooker
here
done that in a minute especially when
you see her
military man is so sexy
what about it are you serious
not scared by the way um
that the whole military men thing are
sexy is is another
hooker line of course um you make
30 000 a year to kill iraqi children
it's not exactly the sexiest job in the
world
oh honey you make 30 thousand a year to
kill babies
oh [ __ ] 30 000 a year i bet you got a
really nice
ford mustang at 29 interest don't forget
it's depreciating in value
oh [ __ ] girl oh i met this man let me
tell you something he and the military
girl
he make baby baby he making like 32 000
a year
to protect israel's interests and
protect oil fields and pedophile
warlords in afghanistan
oh he is sexy girl
so um
that's not nice guys if you're in the
military by the way
uh thank you for your service
your piece of [ __ ]
so uh this is he he finally talks we're
into going to the hotel room this is him
heading into the hotel room
now we haven't seen her you got to think
like this guy's charging like three four
thousand dollars
so the guys pick up hot chicks of course
you got to get hot chicks
the hot chicks what kind of hot chick
are you talking about
you're laughing as you know i know
let's uh went back
that's good
check my windows we're good
all right just be careful crossing
someone says you could tell he's a
military guy because he bought a dodge
charger and crashed in his first day
back
[Laughter]
i'm used to i'm used to driving a hummer
with no power steering
i don't know it's hard to figure out he
did also say he's sober so
that's a point again but also military
people lie about that that's true
so let's add that to the whole thing
he drives a white civic
yeah okay let's get ready after that
truck
i can't wait to see the hot piece of ass
mike i'm so excited
i mean i'm so excited it's gonna be
[ __ ]
guys get ready get ready to see this
[ __ ]
this muse
thank you
don't worry about it
by the way sexy outfit too cowboy boots
you must be a southern girl
it's all good it's hard to see you're on
a holiday
is that the hot chicks made that is
she looks like leslie jones smoking a
black and mild
she is by the way i had to correct one
of the listeners on night wave because
they go oh she's got a cigarette hanging
out of her mouth too and i said oh no no
sir
no that's a black and mild they're
saying
here's a by the way when you see a woman
smoking a black and while that is a
whole different class of lady
[Laughter]
she looks like awesome kong i've never
met a sexy [ __ ] that smokes black and
wild
ever ever see what my room looks like
when i'm in
traveling
by the way very nice motel you're gonna
notice the kind of things you usually
see in a nice hotel like a pepsi machine
by the way not even a coke machine a
pepsi machine uh out in the hallway you
always want to see those
um just this place is really classy wait
where do you really get a look at this
place
all right there's the pepsi machine
an ice machine wrapped in caution tape
that's always a good
is that a good sign that's cool
do they charge extra to wrap the ice
machine and caution tape
yeah that means somebody probably
peed in the ice machine something
happened to the ice machine
something definitely happened in the ice
machine i will say this
if the ice machine were simply broken
right
it wouldn't require caution tape correct
[Laughter]
imagine using an ice machine at one of
these places
excuse me you got the heater on
oh man
yeah well it's chilly hooker outfits on
the bed by the way
i'm helping you guys with the with the
prosecution's case here
hooker outfits on the bed i also want to
point this out
and this is something that i pointed out
uh when i did this on night wave
an entire unopened box of cereal now
i'm gonna let you guys in on a little
secret um
i've i've seen some hood [ __ ] in my day
i've seen
nobody who's uh a functioning human
being
buys groceries for a hotel room
right am i wrong right like
like we've all stayed in hotels right
we've all bought snacks you go down
especially like this certain a lot of
hotels now you go down to the front desk
and they've
all even the shitty ones have like a
little pantry
that you could get a [ __ ] kitkat bar
or a power aid or something you know
what i mean but like
when you go and buy milk and an entire
box of cereal
that that signifies that i plan on
staying in this dump for a while
that i require groceries for this dump i
just i'm
i'm trying to paint a picture for the
people watching at home or if you're
listening on the podcast
you think it's one of the classy hotels
that has a little fridge
where they could put like their drinks
or no i mean
it's have you seen um
even shitty hotels now i think pretty
much always have at least a shitty
fridge
by the way joshua says in the chat most
hotels have cereal
hotels do not have full-sized boxes of
cereal
yeah they have the little they have the
little cereals the cups
or they have the mini boxes yeah yeah
you're getting the party pack
no nice hotel on the planet sells
regular-sized full-size boxes of
cheerios that was bought
at a [ __ ] gas station across the
street
along with one of those little milks you
know like when you get a quart of milk
yeah that's that is [ __ ] that's
grocery shopping in a motel that means
hooker probably likely no
lucky charms they were lucky charms oh
nice they set you up with two beds
look at you oh you put your hook of
clothes right here
just leave all your but this isn't being
a pickup artist this is buying a hooker
yes it's what it looks like anyway they
don't know that
how but here's my thing right even if
you're a pickup artist
and you're like trying to pass this
hooker off as a real
woman um she's a real person mikey
she's a hooker they're not real people
um
they'll let you pretty much put
cigarettes out on them for the right
place
they're not humans okay so um
but okay so you're a pickup artist
whatever let's say it's not okay
but like even this chick is a mess so
it's like
why would i look to you and go like at
least the other guys we've covered
they go to the ukraine and they buy like
these really hot ukrainian hookers
that at least if you're presenting me as
this as an organic conversation i can go
damn he's he's chatting it up with a
[ __ ] dime piece like
okay all right but he's with like
he's with like an eighty dollar back
page hooker
it's pretty gross
what what are the um
get out of here let me see
well you got personalities huh which
one's your favorite
so again but who are they i know you're
saying mike that they're fooling people
but he can't be thinking he's fooling
people if she's got
outfits like this is a comic-con
he's doing this his target audience
royce are people
who are in their mid to late 20s who
literally say
how do i talk to girls
all right i mean you know what i mean
like that's
he's not dealing with very smart people
these
these
rubes that they're taking money from
aren't exactly geniuses here
wig i like you like vlog
dude look man i'm not even because
you could be a thick girl and still look
all right but she's just ugly
yeah this is just a fat book or tea and
a wig this reminds me godzilla versus
kong came out on hbo i got to check that
out tonight
i take that back this is not booker t
it's actually stevie ray in a rig oh
that's worse
the other guy from harlem heat
i got the breeze you got everything huh
[ __ ] yeah oh look at that oh these are
bomb
you have one of these
they [ __ ] refresh somebody's saying
it's goro which is actually very funny
as well it's this kind of guy
does look like goro from from mortal
kombat i will give you that
this is cool nice little view
nice of what the check cashing store
on sunset yes
cool
what's the matter royce this is really
bad man this is really
i am uncomfortable how are you not
uncomfortable are you uncomfortable
watching this guy [ __ ] crush puss
yes i mean you know
we we goof on him a little bit but good
for him he's killing it